[Music]
joe
huh who's the world's richest man
mr tesla mr tesla
elon muskie he just surpassed mr bezos
that's true as a thursday uh
what was today yeah yeah that's
yesterday it's friday i thought i would
have the the date oh yeah
the 7th of january it's crazy elon musk
is the richest man in the world with 185
billion dollars damn because i remember
jeff bezos was like
way ahead of everyone else how the [ __ ]
did he just
it's because me and your own tesla and
we talk about all the [ __ ] time so
it's all because of us you guys showed
me that
i'm so mad at stocks i yell about it all
the time because like at the beginning
of the year
like the stocks were pretty low on tesla
especially last year in the winter time
and so we should about then it's like
more than quadrupled
yeah so i was just like every time i
looked at it i was like oh i missed the
boat right it has to pop soon
and all the analysts are like it's gonna
pop but it keeps going and then they
split like uh what two months ago three
months ago
down to 400 now it's over 800 so it's
cons like if you look at the stock
market every day that everything's red
tesla's the only one that's green that's
going up it's crazy makes no sense
what are they doing waiting for them to
pop but they refuse to pop
not popping so just to give you a little
insight on
just how hard elon musk came up this
year
so jeff bezos in previous episodes uh
this just within 2020
we've talked about jeff bezos how he
came up like 40 billion
within 2020 right amazon had a great
year since the pandemic started
and he skyrocketed way well past
everyone else
on the the top 50 list or whatever
elon musk started uh in 2020 at the
beginning of the year
he was at 27 billion dollars barely
talked
about in the top 50 richest people on on
the list right
he was the richest person in l.a at 19
billion but he wasn't remotely close to
the conversation of being the richest
man in the world
by 2021 beginning of 2021 now
185 billion holy [ __ ] he dwarfs
jeff bezos rise by a lot i mean it kind
of makes sense right because if you look
at it doesn't
okay well it doesn't make sense but in
my [ __ ] how does it make sense how
does it make sense
because i had the same question but i'm
like okay how does sleep okay okay well
well do you how does that make sense at
all
i don't know what i'm saying but i know
why yeah um so okay this is my theory
and it's a crazy theory because i just
came up with it like 60 seconds ago okay
um so
right now we see the state that the
world is in right uh we don't trust
anyone especially in the u.s nobody
trusts that
maybe they're on the [ __ ] the world
nobody's trusting their government
because there's all these [ __ ] lies
and
now everyone's kind of turning to
conspiracy theories because that seems
to
be the [ __ ] thing that kind of makes
sense at this point then there's alien
type so like
everything that we know as normal is
[ __ ]
just all over the place right and then
you have this angel
elon musk who's trying to save the world
he's trying to
you know he's he's checking out what's
going on in the you know outer space
he's also trying to like uh clean up our
planet like he's the only one that seems
to be doing
the right stuff for us right he goes on
joe rogan whom we all love and he's
[ __ ] smoking a joint and he's talking
about like like uh
i don't know he's just talking about
like uh singularity
and like robot talk yeah pretty much uh
and like like
kind of giving us a heads up and like
warning us and like a lot of people
really trust him and he just has fun you
know what's that have to do with this
network
yeah so what my question is is how does
a
car company surpass a company
that is used by everyone every day
that's the part that's crazy um because
it's not it's not elon
stock but it is elon stark it is
it is that's what i'm saying anytime he
did anything bad okay the first time he
smokes weed what happened to the tesla
drops wow right and then we thought that
was the end of yolanda if spacex does
well tesla does well people
see people because he had a baby this
last year that's why
maybe what's his name so number one
just just looking at it physically right
it's like how can
tesla alone be bigger than the banks
bigger than ourselves
he's gonna save bigger than but what
we're talking about
is individual net worth so amazon is
actually
bigger all these other companies are
bigger the difference is
bezels owns a smaller portion of amazon
versus
tesla owns of i mean elon
owns off tesla so the way he got even
more shares within this year too he
actually increased the share
so if tesla the company is a valued at a
like let's say if you look at just the
math right of everything
like bezels let's say uh right now
amazon's at like 3
000 but i'm gonna make the math easy
let's say it's it's worth
a hundred dollars right but bezels only
owns ten percent of the company that
means bezel himself
only has ten dollars worth in amazon
even though it's his company
now tesla mr tesla on the other hand
let's say it's a hundred bucks
same value right but elon owns 50
so that means elon has 50 bucks net
worth
and jeff bezels has 10 net worth so
that's how
it's calculated because it's individual
net worth not how much their company is
worth
mm-hmm i mean it is their company but
it's like how much do they own of that
right that's why uh elon is so damn rich
because i had this question i asked my
friend i was like wait how does this
even work but it's still just crazy to
me that at the end of the day it's like
if you own a car company even if it's
100 right it's like that's like me
saying like most car companies are doing
terrible i own
a bakery and i'm more balling than
[ __ ] ups
or some [ __ ] that's just like the
concept of it is crazy i think it's
because like tesla
if you look at the stock market is
they're the most approachable brand
you know and they're hyped right like
you're like oh if i'm gonna buy stock or
something what am i gonna
get tesla it's going up and then going
up but that's also why everyone thinks
it's gonna pop because it's overhyped
but it hasn't popped for like six months
buy it i'm waiting but the whatever you
keep yelling
but you haven't bothered i'm staring at
the thousands of dollars i'm not
making fomo don't invest like that
yeah it's crazy that's scary that's not
even touched the stock market
i'm like i don't know what's happening i
don't even want to play it's insane
it is pretty crazy yeah i still don't
understand why it's rocketing so high
compared to
it's speculation right so electrolytion
i think
so okay when you think of toyota do you
think the future
no you think the present when you think
of tesla spacex you think
the future right true so like the reason
why that's popping off is because people
see it
as the new standard for the future
and when you're like investing in the
things you want things
to grow right so like if most people
aren't investing into
four thinking like ford mortars no
they're stable
tomorrow yeah or yeah like maybe they're
going under because they need government
subsidies or whatever they got the new
ecoboost in i know
very efficient but i think like there's
no one out there like tesla right now
that's true
and so that's why they're pumping money
into it because people believe in it so
a lot of like
work like net worth stocks all this
stuff a lot of it has to do with
people's beliefs
not how much um actual value
no a lot of it is just belief and
confidence
because they don't have to be making any
money for it to keep going up and they
don't make a lot of money like tesla
they don't make any money at all they're
pretty much
playing like fantasy football but with
businesses yeah i mean like think about
instagram or like these tech companies
that are being sold for like a billion
dollars right like they don't bring in
a cent but they're evaluated or like
the perception is what makes it sell or
like even crypto
no one's [ __ ] using it like it's just
traded
like it's it's like if i said this is
worth twenty thousand bucks and someone
agrees then we keep trading it back and
forth
and then other people start agreeing
that this is twenty thousand dollars
and then they go wait now i'll buy it
for thirty thousand dollars because i
think it's gonna be forty thousand
dollars
and that's basically what's happening in
the market
and and yeah so i don't know like
pokemon cards
yeah it's because they say a lot of
people agree that it cost that much and
they you know
it's crazy it is [ __ ] crazy so just
give you an idea of
how much money he made in 2020 in the
past 12 months
uh he made just
as much as what bill gates's entire net
worth is
oh my god he made 132 billion dollars in
12 months
you know what's also crazy is is like
back in when back in like 90s and early
2000s
people held those positions for a long
time yeah you know like if you're number
one you're like that for
now it almost feels like it's like
youtube
you know there's a point where i was
like ray william johnson i'm right here
or whatever she's going like this it
feels like now it's like that and it's
like no one's gonna be holding on to it
for very long that's so true and it
seems like it might just go back and
forth because
as rich as elon musk is at 184 billion
it's a bunch of people like right on his
heels the person right on his heels
is jeff bezos at 183 billion
so he's only a billion above bezos so
also his money's more stable right
compared to like um
elon musk like a lot of it comes from
the stock market
so if so if that crashes if the stock
goes down elon it comes right back down
that's true wow
you gotta think like if would he cash
out like what did he do at this point
what's his next move what would what
would you do he believes in this [ __ ]
i wouldn't cash out i don't know
business i don't know business at that
level
and then if you cash out that's a bad
look right you're cashing out on your
own company like
i don't believe in myself oh drop the
entire value down again yeah
it's just i don't know the business at
that level is a different game you guys
true
i don't know if you can cash out can you
dump all those stocks and who's going to
buy it
hey you want to buy some of my stuff
yeah but then you know you don't have
ownership of your company
maybe like a portion of it i mean like a
full cash out i mean yeah maybe i don't
know maybe the banks will buy it well we
made his brain
well first off why would you want to i
don't know it's crazy
yeah i don't know so you can have it in
cold hard cash i don't know
i don't even know if that's what they
can i know i don't know i don't know
i can't comprehend what what that it is
i wouldn't want
185 billion you don't want it no
because like even a billion right i
don't
need it like i don't know what to spend
on it i don't eat it but i want it
i have to i wouldn't welcome that
problem i know i don't need it i did it
i wouldn't want that either
no no it's like it's like this right
like like let's say
um even at 100 million that's a lot of
money to spend
like okay yeah maybe if you want to be a
billionaire you want to own a country
you could spend spend spend
but 185 million you can't even spend
that in a lifetime
that's generational wealth and now you
can build your [ __ ] empire
10 20 the generation you could buy a 747
cover it in feathers and make it look
like a bald eagle
no no what do you do with the other
[ __ ] hundred and
eighty six one decision at a time all
right
185 is not it's
it's a it's like your whole country you
can give them generational wealth for
them oh yeah
multiple it's like so much [ __ ] money
what do you think would happen if
someone attempted to do that it would
deflate
the economy in my opinion it would
deflate the world economy that's why you
can't do like the infinite charity you
know when the people they're like oh
this guy can solve the world's problems
yeah for that split second everyone has
a meal 10 years down the line like the
entire
economy of the world is just destroyed i
don't know but yeah i got to talk to
some economists but that's what i
assume is like if you unload that kind
of money into the world
damn that's crazy i mean it exists
like but it never did before which is
gnarly
it did just somewhere else huh it did
just somewhere else the money just moves
around
or it gets printed that's much money
like
yeah like where is it is it just never
gonna end like
for him no it's just it's above my
pancreas i don't know
economy is a weird thing
you